teaching people about cloud architecture
require some architecting in itself join
us as we talk to Arctic about how they
build that dynamic classrooms on this
episode of stack chat Tim thanks so much
for joining us tell us a little bit more
about what art does yeah so thanks for
having me
you know Arctic is a services enablement
fairman so you know we focus on
consulting specifically in the cloud and
software space a heavy focus on
automation kubernetes GCP platform and
you know kind of on ramping customers
and enabling to do you know things
faster smoother with with more
efficiency and a big part of that is
also helping them run workshops for
their own forms of training yeah so
we're big believers on enabling we're
big believers on you know come in show
somebody how to do something show
someone how to fish
write teach someone how to fish and then
they can kind of you know be
self-sustained you know so the idea is
workshops enable us to get our customers
to be very comfortable with the
technology and get them to get them to
touch the technology that is ultimately
going to shape how they move forward so
what's an example of what a workshop
might look like that an instructor would
put together yeah so an example a great
example is our Jiki workshops and gk
workshops have been very successful for
us and just you know getting customers
familiar with all the concepts inside of
gk how to get workloads into there and
how to manage it day to operation sort
of stuff and you know ultimately it
turns out like a shared repository and a
shared project structure inside of GCP
that houses what we call our instructor
environment and that instructor
environment we onboard instructors into
there we onboard them into our git
repository and effectively they come
prepared with a student list and all it
takes really to run a workshop is a
student list and you know some students
obviously and you know kind of we we get
them to build out a student list pass it
in to ansible ansible ultimately takes
care of the templating function taking
that student list and effectively
building out terraform plans each
student ends up with their their own
environment so you know part of our
design goal was making sure that as
students were on boarded and as we were
running the workshops we weren't running
into the traditional sort of you know
student for accidentally logged into
student one
environment is an example and you know
you end up with that collision stuff and
you know very much we wanted to provide
an experience to our end users that
allowed them to have their own
environment if they want to break it
they break it you know and if they want
to you know test the boundaries of
something that we don't have prescribed
in a lab then you know we want to enable
them to do that we want to enable them
to sort of find the edges on their own
as well so it's a big balance between
like flexibility and also you know being
able to really quickly get these things
going up and running sometimes you might
have students that don't show up or
changes that need to be made and the
system was designed to support all of
that yes absolutely so you know part of
what we wanted to do up front was you
know kind of give a repeatable structure
for automation and a repeatable
structure to offer these workshops in a
very streamlined way but then also give
the capabilities so that if you know
you're running a lab with us and all of
a sudden you tear down your cluster
which has happened and all of a sudden
you're gke clusters dead you know
ultimately you know there's merit and
troubleshooting there's merit and kind
of going through the works of
understanding how GK works and how to
maybe you know we spin up a new cluster
at the same time it's a workshop and we
need to sometimes get to to end up job
really quickly and so it makes more
sense to rebuild your left you know that
whole structure allows us to target only
your lab resources as an example and
effectively just respawn and you know
let you get on your way what does an
example student infrastructure look like
yeah so the student infrastructure you
know sort of similar to the instructor
environment and that you know there's a
GK cluster inside of an ephemeral
project so that you know real difference
is each and every one of the student
projects is an ephemeral project itself
and then we would on board each of those
students through the automation with the
right permissions inside of that project
so they've got the right cluster
permissions all that sort of stuff and
then ultimately inside of each one of
those environments they have their own
GK cluster with sto enabled and a bunch
of the tooling and so we run them
through things like cloud build and GCR
and image scanning and all that stuff
all at the project level and very much
give them their own customized and
unique environment by controlling it all
tightly with the lifecycle management
inside of tear form allows us to kind of
you know make sure that we can spin it
up quickly modify and manage it as as
things break or as things need to change
but then also very much be able to
tear down with you know very little
effort so with the instructors being
able to come in there kind of configure
everything and then having all the
automation come in and complete that
actual running this is kind of a
naturally volatile environment right
there spinning things up spinning things
down I'm sure this isn't like the this
wasn't just a bill that once and it
worked kind of solution what would you
say like as you were tweaking it a long
time especially the automation portion
what would you say kind of the biggest
lesson you learned or the biggest kind
of hurdle you overcame you know the idea
behind it is we very quickly settled on
terraform to handle that the actual
resource life cycle stuff you know the
the the idea of sort of putting this all
in code and kind of managing that way
was you know obviously very early design
goal part of what we had tried to do
very early on was sort of used terraform
for taking that student list in and
really building out the environment that
way inside a terraform and running
things on a loop and you know if you had
20 students well that's 20 projects 20
clusters and you know it should be very
repeatable so even enabling service api
is that the project level becomes a you
know a pretty significant exercise at
scale you know it's one thing to start
up a project and start up a gk cluster
and you know plumb the various elements
but we're talking about doing it 20
times if you've got a you know a 20
student class ultimately what that
turned into is a little bit of a
nightmare around that
what happens if somebody's sick and you
know they call in before the workshop
starts and we need to you know
substitute you know person a for person
B and you know ultimately that turned
into a bit of a nightmare very early on
and it allowed us to or it showcased us
that we we really needed to rethink that
and so I'd say the biggest learning
lesson was are sort of integrating
ansible into the whole scenario so not
only is the the resource structure and
the project structure very ephemeral but
the actual terraform code itself is very
ephemeral so that was probably the
biggest thing we learned under this
whole theme was you know sometimes you
got to pick the right tool for the job
that makes a lot of sense thanks so much
for coming in and telling us a little
bit about how you built this
architecture noise thanks for having me
interested in trying out terraform for
yourself check out the collection of GCP
terraform examples to get started
thanks for watching and make sure to
subscribe for more great Google cloud
platform content we'll see you next time
on stack chat
[Music]
you